The internal problem is how do you deal
with tragedy and malevolence and you can
say,
well,
I'm not prepared.
It's like,
yeah,
fair enough.
Unsurprising.
Especially if you were over protected as
a child.
It's not a good idea to overprotect your
kids because the snakes are going to
come into the garden no matter what you
do,
and so then you instead of trying to
keep the damn snakes away,
what you do is you are a mere child with
something that can help them chop them
into pieces and make the world out of
them so that the trick for human
thriving in the face of suffering and
malevolence is strength,
not protection.
It's a completely different idea.
We also know this clinically.
We know for example,
that if you treat people with exposure
therapy for agora phobia,
which is roughly speaking,
the fear of chaos,
I would say the fear of everything.
You don't make them less afraid.
You make them braver.
It's not the same thing because with an
agoraphobic,
see what happens to them is the fault.
They never conceptualized death and
suffering.
They're naive,
right?
It.
It never enters their.
The theater of their imagination and
it's because they're protected from it,
but then something happens.
This often happens to women in their
forties because they're.
They're the people most likely to
develop agoraphobic.
Something happens there.
They've been protected from chaos by
authority their entire life,
so maybe they had an overprotective
father and then they went to an
overprotective boyfriend and then they
went to an over protective husband and
maybe they were willing to be subjugated
to all three of those because of the
project protection.
Right,
so so that's the bargain.
They stay weak and dependent and maybe
they have to because that's the only way
they can appeal to the person who's
hyper protective,
but the price they pay for that is that
they're not sufficiently competent and
then something happens in their life.
Often in their forties,
they develop heart palpitations maybe as
a consequence of menopause.
Their heart starts to beat a radically
and they think,
oh no,
death.
It's like,
well,
who are you going to talk to about that?
Right.
There's no protection from authority for
that.
Or maybe their friend gets divorced or
maybe their sister dies or something
like that.
It brings up the specter of mortality
and maybe the specter of malevolence and
mortality and it brings it up in a way
that authority recourse to authority
cannot solve,
and so then they have panic attacks.
What happens?
They go out,
they get afraid,
they feel their heart beating.
Then they get afraid of their heart
beating because they think,
oh no,
I'm going to die.
And they think,
oh no,
I'm going to die and I'm going to make a
fool of myself while I'm doing it and
attract a lot of attention.
So the two big fears come up,
mortality and social judgment,
and then they have a panic attack.
It's like fight or flights going out of
control.
Very,
very unpleasant.
Then they start to avoid the places
they've had a panic attack.
Then they ended up not being able to go
anywhere.
So then tie A.
Matt has come back,
write a huge monster,
a little victim.
And so what do you do with them?
Well,
there's no saying no.
There's no tire map that's done right
there.
Naivety is over.
They,
they've had a direct contact with the
threat of mortality and social judgment.
They've met the terrible mother and
they've met the terrible father and
there's no going back.
There's no saying,
oh,
the world is safe.
It's not safe.
Not at all.
The fact that you think it's safe means
that you were living in an unconscious
bubble that was sort of provided to you
by your culture.
It's a gift and now that's been
shattered and so now what do you do?
Well,
the answer is you retreat until you're
in your house and there's nowhere you
can go.
You're the ultimate frozen rabbit,
right?
And your life is hell because you can't
function.
The alternative is let's take apart the
things you're afraid of.
Let's expose you to them carefully and
programmatically,
and then you'll learn that you can.
You're actually tougher than you think.
You never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise,
so to speak.
When you had an opportunity to go out
and explore or withdraw because you were
afraid,
you chose to withdraw because you were
so it's not only that you were over
protected,
often it's that you were willing to take
advantage of the fact that you are
overprotected and run back there
whenever you had the opportunity,
you know,
so maybe you're a kid in the playground,
right?
And you're having some trouble with
other kids and you know,
in the back of your mind,
I should deal with deal with this
myself,
but you go and tell your mom and get her
to intervene and you know that that's
not right.
You know that you're breaking the social
contract,
but it's easier.
And so that's what you do.
You run off to an authority figure and
hide behind the great father,
right?
Roughly speaking,
while the problem with that is you don't
learn how to do it yourself.
So then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40.
So then you take people out,
you say,
well,
what are you afraid of?
Rank it from one to 10.
So 10 is we'll make a list of 10 things
you're afraid of the least,
the thing that we're least afraid of.
We'll call number 10.
So we'll start with that.
Okay,
well,
I'm afraid of elevators.
Okay,
well let's.
Let's look at a picture of an elevator.
Let's have you imagine being in an
elevator.
Let's go out to an elevator and let you
watch the terrible jaws of death open
because that's how you're responding to
it symbolically,
right?
And you're going to do that.
Add it at the.
The closest proximity you can manage.
You find out,
you go do that.
It works.
You're nervous as hell,
especially from an anticipatory
perspective,
shaking.
You go out,
you stop,
you watch it happen,
and he actually calmed down.
You do that 10 times and it no longer
bothers you.
Well,
what you've learned that you didn't die,
but more importantly than that,
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death.
That's what you've learned,
and then you move a little closer and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and finally
you're back in.
What's no longer the elevator from a
symbolic perspective?
It's a tomb,
right?
It's,
it's,
it's a place of enclosure and isolation
and you learn.
It turns out I can withstand that and
then you're much more together,
much more confident,
and that's often one of the things that
often happens in situations like that.
I've seen this multiple times,
is that if you run someone through an
exposure training process like that and
toughen them up,
they'll often start standing up to
people around them in a way they never
did before because they wouldn't stand
up for themselves before because they
weren't willing to undermine that
protection.
See,
if you're protecting me,
I can't bother you because I can't
afford to forsake your protection,
so if I'm going to play that game,
I'm going to be high hide behind you,
then I can't challenge you,
so that's no good because that's
sometimes white people.
You see this with guys very frequently.
They're still deathly afraid of their
fathers judgment when they're in their
thirties or forties.
It's like,
well,
why?
Well,
because they still want to believe that
there's someone out there that knows and
so they're willing to accept the
subjugation because it doesn't force
them to challenge the idea that there's
someone out there that knows because
that's the advantage of having your
father as a judge,
right?
Because he knows,
well,
what if he doesn't?
What if no one knows any better than
you?
Well,
that's a rough thing.
You don't until you realize that you're
not an adult.
Right?
That's really technically the point of
realization of adulthood is that no one
actually knows what you should do more
than you do.
I mean,
it's a horrible realization because what
the hell do you know?
It's a terrible realization and people
will often pick slavery,
permanent slavery to the spirit of the
great father,
let's say over that realization,
and it's completely understandable,
but the problem with it is,
is that there's more to you than you
think,
and so if you continue to hide behind
that figure,
then you never have a chance to
understand that there's more to you than
you think far more than you think.
Maybe there's enough to you so that you
can actually withstand the threat of
mortality without collapsing.
Maybe even withstand the threat of
malevolence without collapsing.
Who knows?
It's certainly possible and it's not an
abstract question.
It's exactly the sort of question that
you address in the psychotherapeutic
process.
It's always the question that you
address and the answer is often in the
affirmative because people can get
unbelievably tough and you know that
because people work in emergency wards
in hospitals,
right?
Or they work in,
in palliative care wards or they work as
mortuary assistance.
I mean these people have bloody rough
jobs,
you know,
are there on the front line of police
investigation into,
you know,
highness child abuse crimes and so
they're confronting malevolence on a
regular basis and you know,
those are very stressful jobs,
but people do them and some people do
them without even being damaged by them.
Although that's a harder thing because
you can see horrible things,
you know,
things you will never forget.